in the meeting,
we could still have somebody.
Control it. All right,
I shared the link in there.
Vanessa, I did get your notes.
While somebody's reporting out,
I will process that and share the link in
here. Or rather, I share the link to you.
Yeah.
I don't think everybody needs that,
unless you want me to share it in here.
No, you mean for the other project? Yeah,
you can do that after this meeting.
Yeah.
It's okay.
Okay,
just making sure because I did forget
Yeah, thank you. Yeah.
about it. All right,
so let me share my screen so we can get
started.
Oh no, that's not what I want.
We need to know what kind of music you
listen to, Sean.
Oh man, I'm a music producer.
I have a whole,
Right.
Yeah?
Yeah.
I have a whole record label.
Yeah.
Ohh!
All right, so...
Now we know. Anybody want to go platinum,
we'll go platinum with Sean.
Ohh.
Yeah.
So yeah, it's pretty straightforward.
It's the same bucket that we have.
Anything,
just anything that you see that needs to
be updated,
just speak it naturally and it will get
updated. And if when I send you the notes,
for whatever reason you don't see
something notated, just let me know.
because sometimes it does miss things.
But if we make it a...
In real time or after the meeting it gets
updated?
No, after the meeting.
I was trying to figure out how to do it
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
in real time. It's not hard,
but I just need some time to like
prototype it and play it and test it and
all that stuff.
So that would be the next step.
There is a way, there has to be a way,
and I'll figure it out. But for now,
you're looking at the delay of me just.
you know, synthesizing it,
which takes like 5 minutes.
Uh-huh.
I just need to do it. All right.
Oh.
So my question still is that...
All well and good, but like I,
I would like to, I know, you know,
But...
So, so to answer that, so to answer,
so to answer that,
I like to ask extra, edit. Yeah.
I do have that built in.
I think I know where you're going. If not,
I apologize for interrupting you.
It's going to have different versions.
So if you click on here,
you could see where we were on those
dates we had the meetings.
Uh-oh.
See,
it says new versions are added after each
meeting transcript is processed.
No, not where I was born with it, but so.
If you look, so this,
so let me ask the question,
maybe let me back up.
Let me ask the question.
Mm.
And.
This is really not a tracker.
It is really just a...
Beautifully curated.
Meeting notes.
Because I can't go in and click and
change the status,
something that is in progress,
for example, it's not like...
Like our Excel spreadsheet,
where you can go in and have the ability
to.
Add, add, add something in, in.
Real time.
Mmh.
Are you guys there?
I'm not hearing anything.
Oh, no,
Sean is because Sean is typing over here
and his agent to see to see if this is
what I'm asking to do.
Oh, okay. I didn't see that part. Okay.
Okay.
Okay,
let's have that go in the background and
then I should, once that process,
I should be able to refresh it and we can
see that.
But I think for now we can just go down.
Okay.
But I'm working on that right now, Tricia.
Yep.
Mhm.
All right, so first one,
we have WCM guidelines.
Does Vanessa have you as the lead on that?
Yeah, we're still working through that.
I know Andrea is still working on centers,
Yes.
I believe, and I'll be meeting.
We are still working on the athletics and
also another section of the guidelines.
So
that is still a work in progress.
Excuse me, Vanessa,
I finished the centers, the cloning them,
Mhm.
I finished them.
Okay, very good. Thank you. The Sanders,
yeah.
Is that what you're referring to, right?
Okay, yeah,
I thought I sent you an email yesterday.
Okay, they're done though.
Okay.
So, Andrea completed the centers.
I sent Vanessa an email.
Yes.
Okay,
I'm just saying that for context because
She, yeah, she completed her sections.
Mm.
I won't know the voices.
Up my sections, right?
Okay.
All right,
moving on to the analytics dashboard
slash Google governance.
So I updated the Google governance
Okay.
document and I shared it yesterday with
the team.
No.
Yeah.
So now I'm just waiting for feedback.
I know Charlene received it because I met
Yeah.
with her yesterday and she said she's
taking a look at it.
follow up with Farrah.
I.
Later today, and Tricia,
you have it as well.
move any moving on.
Once we get further on that,
we know how everything's going to go.
We get our accounts,
then we can move on to the next phase,
which is actually setting up the
dashboard.
Is there a meeting scheduled to, for,
is there another like a follow-up meeting
scheduled for?
Not yet.
It's going to be pending once we reach
That, okay.
out to them.
So once I send the updated Google
governance document,
then that's when we'll be setting up the
meeting.
They did have a meeting scheduled.
I thought first half a split second it
was for the Google,
but it's for the AI initiative with the
same team.
And that's going to be on Thursday.
So I'm sure I would love for us to have
us locked in because really all you all
the pending item on our end is just to
review it and make sure we're all aligned.
It's essentially just providing,
it's essentially what everything we
Ohh.
discussed in the meeting plus Charlene's
notes.
And then actually my deliverables from
the meeting as well, all in one package.
Oh
Thanks.
So once we all have to get the thumbs up,
then we can send it out to the bigger
The.
Search.
team for their feedback.
Go.
And then go from there.
Because at that point,
it's just the bigger team accepting it or
adjusting it. Because if they accept it,
then they should be able to move forward
and they let us know what that timeline
looks like.
Alright, back to school, Felicia.
The.
I, I don't have anything right now.
I haven't even went through all my emails
yet to catch up.
Anything from you, Vanessa,
to update Felicia on?
Um...
I think in our last team meeting,
I know Felicia was not there,
that we had agreed that although the
original launch date was 13th,
No.
that we would move forward with the 22nd
of June and that the OOC would just put
Beer.
generic language regarding to back to
school. And once the districts
back to school landing page is up to date,
then the link to the
site would be added to that shared app,
but we're still moving forward with the
June 22nd.
So we can't schedule in that showcase
because like our district page wouldn't
Noel.
be ready yet.
But I know that we also for the school
Okay.
news is what we told the WCM before they
leave to schedule for the July 13th day.
So I don't know if y'all okay with that.
Oh, y'all gonna,
Right, so...
we gonna have to go back in and change
that.
Right, so it's.
Date for them.
Ohh.
No, that the school news is fine.
It's just the banner we're trying to put
Yeah.
up because of our conflicting schedules
with the team and trying to ensure that
we get them. Unfortunately,
we cannot schedule a banner in final site.
All the banners are manually added and
also removed.
So what we are doing,
that although the district site is not
going to be ready, that's okay.
We just need the shared app on the...
School.
the shared app that's under school
resources, right?
Mhm.
Just to have generic back-to-school
information, right? And then typically...
Oh, I have that. I have that. I have that.
I have that paragraph. I just,
Exactly.
I know that it gets to,
if they click on it,
Right.
it kind of directs them to the district
landing page,
but I have the information for that.
I just didn't want to change it because I
Right.
know something else is there at the
moment, but I, yeah.
That's fine, I can, I can take that date.
Right, so since, right,
so since the district site is not going
to be ready,
we just won't include the hyperlink,
but we can still have the language
because on the language it says check
below to see the school resources,
school resource, check below,
Okay.
something in the language says view the
links below to check to see what your
You.
school is offering.
Open the song.
Whatever, that's still fine.
Okay.
Okay. All right. Thank you.
The.
All right,
so we're going to move on to WCM audits
for schools. Nakesha?
Yeah.
we are moving forward in touching the
schools that are in failed and incomplete
status and completing certain sections
for them.
The sections are school counseling
section, the academic pathway section,
Yeah.
school news,
back to school, Head Start, VPK,
and SuccessFactors,
and the specialized programs pages.
We are,
that's what we are currently touching for
those failed and incomplete school sites.
But I have not went back over to see if
any new submissions have been
Have been have came in.
As of I want to say.
Last.
Last Thursday, I haven't checked it.
Okay.
I just want to add,
thank you to those of you guys on the
team that's working on the summer audits
that Nakesha just mentioned.
Rudy did send out an email maybe about an
hour ago.
If you guys can just take a look and just
confirm that you've seen the message
because there are some updates regarding
VPK and also specialized programs.
Mhm.
OK, and Nakesha,
I just checked - there's only two
additions that have not been touched yet.
No, I'm not. I'm not.
We're not talking about that one.
Yeah.
We're talking about the actual phase one
audit.
Call.
Never mind.
Yeah.
Thank you, anyways.
Okay. All right,
so I'm going to move on to departments,
Yes.
WCM audit for departments.
So we are working on getting those
completed by this week. And we will,
that's the goal.
And we will see if we make the goal.
Um...
Department Audit Dashboard.
Oh.
Oh, this could be moved to complete it.
No, no, no, not yet.
I got to put it on the,
I got to put the embed on the on the hub
in the hub. You just added it to this way.
So I have to do similar process and add
it to the hub as well.
When I get to it, I'll figure it out.
I just don't have a clear pack.
So I don't think there's a clean embed,
right?
You have to do it through PowerPoint or
the way we did it for Sway. Vanessa.
No, not on the district site.
District site you can just embed using an
Okay.
embed element.
Gotcha. All right, awesome. So sweet.
Right, were the colors updated?
I, I don't know. I mean, I don't.
I think the issue was,
I don't know what colors to change it to,
so I think that...
District colors.
Oh, I guess. All right, yeah, I mean,
yeah, okay,
Okay.
then time to give them this town district.
What does that mean though?
He can use the same colors that was for
the school dashboard.
No, they're not.
The colors you're using? No,
do you have like a peachy orange?
I think that's,
I think that was the simplification of it.
I thought that's,
I thought those were the colors of it
because I haven't looked at it that often.
So I'll just tell them to use the same
colors as the school.
So note is for Brannon to use the same
colors as the school's dashboard for this
dashboard.
And I'll give it another eyeball as well,
just in case I see missing things.
Ohh.
Okay.
So those,
that's the action item to be completed by
Friday. Oh, are we,
we're still here Friday.
It starts next week, right?
News this week.
No.
No, you'll be here by yourself.
This week.
Oh, where?
Since last week, right?
So,
are you not working long days like the
Noel.
No, it wasn't last week.
rest of us?
That was a joke.
Oh, okay. Okay. No,
because I was speaking to some of you too.
Oh.
So some of you,
you guys are going to laugh at me then.
Mm.
All right. No, no school this Friday.
No work this Friday.
Yeah.
Happy accidents, right?
So that's what that is.
Security concerns that...
Yes,
we need a meeting because we need to move
Yeah, that's.
this forward.
I see we have a deadline of August 10th,
so before school starts back.
Um...
So do we want to have,
so I think we should have a session to
figure out how to do this from the final
side side.
Because my solution was going a
completely different direction for the
platform,
but I don't think that is a solution.
So we got to figure out how to do it
within final side.
Right.
And I think that's going to take us like.
Yes.
Having a...
So should I reach out to Sue to schedule
something with their support?
I love that, yes.
I was actually talking about us,
but that is a more efficient way of using
our time.
Yeah.
And so did she cancel her,
did she cancel her meeting this week
Wait, are we talking about?
because she's meeting with you guys?
Oh no, we can ask her next week then.
We'll wait till next. No.
So she asked us what would be available
because she had something.
So I believe I asked Vanessa and we had
agreed on.
10:30 on the 15th, maybe.
For Wednesday.
I don't.
Ohh.
But just to,
I don't think we need to include Sue on
Okay.
the security concerns because final site,
we can just contact support.
Final site has a feature where you can
just put in a code.
Yeah, I don't think we need Sue. I think,
I think,
And we can log down pages.
I think that would be taking up too much
of our time when we could be discussing
Yeah.
other things with Sue to Vanessa's point.
I think we just need to.
No, but I was just saying, Sue,
to coordinate with having a support
person,
that we schedule a call with the support
person that she can schedule,
coordinate that. That's her role.
Yeah, you know what?
It's gonna take way too much time if
we're waiting, I'm sorry.
Okay.
Okay,
so we're going to just call support
Okay.
randomly.
We have a meeting and then we just call
No, no, no.
in support and we get some random person
that haven't had the chance to look.
Tricia is right. Tricia is right.
Us calling support is different than Sue
calling support saying,
this is a task you're going to work on.
I think it's going to be a...
Because then they actually would have
some time to look at it and come prepared.
Yeah.
I'd rather,
rather than when we call in and they're
like, huh, what should I say?
Where are they? What's the folder?
But it's just the feature, we, I'm sorry,
because we were on a call with final site,
No.
Ohh.
Sean and I,
and they explained to us how to lock down
a section and how to create a code and
share the passcode with everyone and
moving forward if you access this.
So it's...
Oh.
Ohh,
so you guys have the instructions then?
We met with them some months ago.
I'm not remembering each step.
I'm just saying that I don't think it
warrants involving Sue to set up a
Yeah.
meeting and then we wait two months to
get it done when we can just contact
support and say, you know,
So is there a ticket for that one that if
you guys contact the support,
shouldn't they have a ticket that we can
go back to that we can reference that
Uh, it wasn't...
when we call them so that they can look
it up? No?
It wasn't an issue,
so I don't believe a ticket was initiated.
It was, how do you, it was a question,
and how do we make this happen?
Oh.
As A helpless person,
they supposed to log everything that come
in so that they somebody know that
they're working.
OK, so maybe there is.
I think it would be just easier just to
present it again versus us having to find
That's fine, we can.
what that ticket was,
unless they can reference it by topic and
That.
tell us what the ticket is.
Unless Vanessa wants to search.
I'm good.
Alright, so let's just, let's just.
Okay,
so is it an action for me to reach out to
Sue or are we not reaching out to Sue?
Let's just, no,
don't reach out to Sue for this. Let's,
No.
Vanessa,
if we could set some time up today or
tomorrow,
I don't know what your schedule looks
Yeah.
like.
And we just maybe dedicate 30 minutes, 45,
Mhm.
an hour,
however long you think it would take for
us to figure this out. I'm game.
I can make myself available.
All right, I'm scheduling it now.
And if we don't get anywhere with this,
then we'll go your route, Tricia.
Okay.
Anyhow, she, anyhow she,
anyhow I said she,
anyhow they come back and say,
we got to escalate this,
then we'll take that ticket and we'll
route it through Sue.
Okay.
That way she's aware of it because she
did say to do that.
Oh
Okay.
Okay,
I just scheduled those for 3:00 today.
OK.
Alrighty.
So that is the action item for security
concerns. Next,
we've got Google Governance,
which I probably...
Kit.
But.
I want to take the...
I want to take the, what is it called,
the dashboard and put that to pending and
then the Google governance will be my
report out because I essentially did the
Google governance report out for the
dashboard and the dashboard technically
is pending until the Google governance is
done. So make that update onto this deck.
School and department changes.
School and department changes. That's me.
Can we update this title?
I think this has to do with the...
What?
the closing of schools and the department
changes. I don't.
Oh, oh, oh, I see, I see, I see, I see.
In the fact that I didn't pick it up
immediately, you're right,
it should change. So, org chart changed,
org chart structure.
Procedures.
Okay.
Is that convoluted or chart project?
or chart restructuring.
How about department and school closures?
It's not disclosures,
some of them are just being Reed.
Ohh, just OK, being moved or whatever.
How about,
how about school and department?
I think that I look at it,
it's pretty clean, isn't it?
Okay.
School and department changes.
I mean, it took me a second to get there,
but I can't think of anything better than
Yeah.
that.
Okay, that's fine.
Anybody else?
Ideas.
Or maybe we should include like a
description of what.
Okay.
In in this layout,
like a description of what the task is,
because I see underneath it.
Because that one's showing an action item.
I seem like that's the only, you're right.
So the descriptions I'm talking to,
talking to you, Claude,
Oh.
the descriptions should be descriptions
and not notes. If you're,
if they read like notes,
put them into the notes section, please.
Yeah.
And I'll do a sweep to make sure once we
get the updated version.
I did a recorder update on this.
Let's see if it took, give me a second,
do a hard refresh on here.
No.
Oh.
All right.
So I put a recorder button on here.
So let's see if it works for the next one.
So now we're doing anything pending on
Ohh.
that.
So I have been getting a lot of
information from the schools.
I have the org chart change restructuring.
So I'm going to put together a little
brief on that and I'll share it out with
everybody once it's done.
And then you can see
Did you already send me stuff about the
schools?
Kind of like which questions and stuff.
I believe a list in our previous meeting,
a list of the schools that are closing
that that was shared.
Okay,
so I'll reference the previous meeting,
meeting minutes to,
and I'll share those meeting minutes just
in case I didn't process them. All right,
so let's go ahead and do,
I'm going to try the kickoff because we
did get some updates on that.
I'm going to use this to see if it works.
So the idea is if I hit record,
it should be transcribing in real time.
And then it will hopefully update it
after maybe like one or two minutes.
So let's see.
Chat one.
Oh, see,
this is how you gotta play with things
before you release them. All right,
I'll play, I keep playing with it.
No.
It's capturing it regardless.
So to kick off.
So the kickoff,
so I'll update everyone just in case you
weren't in the meetings. I know Felicia,
you've missed a few of our conversations
regarding the kickoff. So
Ohh.
The end result,
people are walking out of Pompano Beach
High School feeling like they're ready to
take on their websites.
They met a few new people.
They know all the faces behind the IAQ
Both of them.
requests. And they're like,
oh my goodness, I can't believe I'm a WCM.
Yeah.
I get the honor to be
Okay.
in this position and tell the story of my
school,
I'm going to put this on my my headstone
and when I'm done and going on to the
next life. That is that is our goal.
That's what we're striving for with this.
Yeah.
Janis.
Yeah.
Everything else is just going to be the
steps to that to that destination. And
Yeah.
We decided Pompano Beach because a lot of
us have attended and even facilitated
events there. We are using the work,
the auditorium as a gathering place for
Ohh.
everyone for lunch.
Certain sessions will be held out of
there,
but we'll also be using the classrooms.
for different call outs,
different pull out sessions.
We do around a few topics and ideas and
all that can be captured.
And I think we may have a document
floating around somewhere. If not,
we need to make one.
But the guts are there.
The update is that we did parallel paths.
to find out about booking.
Vanessa was able to get some good
information from Brenda Markley,
who has hosted and done events there
Okay.
before.
Brenda provided us with information
regarding costs.
She said typically for their big events,
they pay around $1,000.
Total, and that's for security,
that's for things, this, that,
Yeah.
Okay.
and the other. Am I correct on that,
Vanessa? Did I miss anything? So I,
Yeah.
That is correct. That is correct.
at the same time,
had reached out to Farrah because I know
Yeah.
that she's worked with them in the past.
with Pompano,
with her being part of OSPA before she
came here. And she told me that,
she gave me the information,
she put me actually connecting me with
the school and the person that does
Yeah.
everything.
And they let us know that September 11th
is available as of right now.
then that's when Vanessa reached out to
Brenda to see if they were going to have
I.
a TLC meeting on that date.
We didn't want to conflict with them.
Yeah.
As of now, they haven't booked their date,
so they're working around us.
Ohh.
So they put in their calendar not to do
anything for September 11th.
So all that to say,
September 11th is available.
Right now,
the only thing that we're sorting out is
the cost.
Farrah got back to me after I shared the
Oh.
email Brenda sent to Vanessa,
and she said that she doesn't believe the
district should have to pay anything,
and she's going to double check.
Because I,
because my question to Farrah was like,
okay, are you okay?
If we move forward with this,
Yeah.
us covering, you know,
a portion of that cost, you know,
you're going to be the ultimately 1 to
make that call.
And then that's when she said she doesn't
believe that we,
the district pays for events like this.
So that's where we are right now.
We're waiting to hear back from Farrah
whether or not we would have to pay.
And if so, what is that?
district quote unquote price that maybe
the TLC committee isn't aware of. So.
Right,
and some of the things that were on that
list, for example,
so Pompano is closed on Fridays.
So that means we would have to pay for
security,
we would have to pay for a janitor,
we would have to pay for their microtech.
So that's where some of the cost also
includes in addition to renting out the
space as well.
Yeah, and to Farrah's point,
I would imagine that like something like
that,
especially if it's servicing every
department at every school,
shouldn't have to come out of one or two
departments' budgets.
There should be something,
Mhm.
there should be some sort of like
professional development budget that's
available.
you know,
for that's something that's going to
Yes.
apply to literally the whole district,
if you think about it. So we'll see.
Bing.
Ohh.
All right, so the TLC committee is like,
I need a refund.
But one of the things...
The school and department changes.
All right, kickoff.
Anything I missed on kickoff? I mean,
we could probably have a whole meeting on
this,
but I just wanted to catch people up.
Yeah,
that's what I was going to actually
suggest is that we should break out into
like a subcommittee on this topic because
we need to discuss, you know,
what are the training classes that we're
going to have?
What are the different sessions?
Who's going to be conducting those
sessions?
Yeah.
What are the presentations going to
include? So there's more to this.
that we really need to dive into and
really invest some time just to make sure
that it is very successful.
And also we talked last week that we
asked everyone to come to this meeting
with some theme ideas and slogans.
M.
So that's also part of,
I'm not sure if anyone had a chance to do
that just yet.
but we also talked about introducing some
of those theme ideas on this call.
So did we want to put something in the
books for later this, oh no, tomorrow,
next week regarding this?
Just so it doesn't, you don't have,
we don't remember it again next Wednesday
that we need to have this meeting?
No.
So you're saying to create a reoccurring
meeting for the kickoff?
No, not reoccurring. I mean, like,
it could be a one-off.
We still stick with our one meetings,
but like, do we want to,
because we still have to,
I still think regardless of the situation,
we should save these meetings,
the Wednesday meetings,
we should go through everything.
But if we, like, we need to,
Mhm.
out of everything we discussed right now,
I think the only thing we would need
one-on-one,
like an individual meeting for would be
the kickoff.
Mhm.
So I would say that could be a meeting
just for next week.
And if we decide it needs to be a
reoccurring meeting,
then we decided at that point.
But I think it might be premature to say
that for right now.
All right,
I'll go ahead and schedule something for
next week for the kickoff meeting.
OK, and then for...
Keeping in mind that I told Sue that this
time next week,
we were using that for her meeting,
1030 on Wednesday.
Wait, say that again? I'm sorry.
Remember when I asked you what time was
good and I thought it was Wednesday at
1030. So that's what I told you.
Yes.
So, which is this meeting?
Right, so that's for Sue's meeting,
but the kickoff would be a different time.
Right, right. No, no, I got that,
but I'm just,
because I know Sean said keep this
meeting to go over this,
but we're going to use this time next
week to meet with Sue.
So are you okay after the SU meeting that
we at least have a 30 minute review?
Like it could be a laser one?
Sure.
Mhm.
Okay, cool.
All right,
so you'll work on that and just let us
know, Vanessa, right?
Just confirm me before I move on.
Yeah, I'm scheduling it now. Yep.
All right. QA process.
So that is still pending and let's get a
I.
date on that. So kickoff, actually,
let's get some deadlines on these things.
Department audit dashboard.
That, oh no, see, I was thinking Friday.
Monday.
Let me help you out with some dates here.
Monday, Monday, Monday. Oh, no, no, no,
no, no. 15th,
June 15th for the department audit
dashboard, because it's already done.
It just needs to be finalized.
And then for your kickoff,
what did we consider the deadline?
It's too.
have all of the all to have the plan
solidified for us to know what all the
No.
action items are leading up until the
kickoff of the actual event.
Is that okay for the for us determining
if this is this particular task is
complete?
What is the date?
This September 11th is the date of the
event.
Right,
but then the tasks need to be completed
prior to that, though.
Yes,
so you're saying what is the actual date?
Anyone have any suggestions?
Right.
I would say the first week in August,
suggesting.
I think we should be before that,
because we're not saying when all of our
tasks are going to be done,
because our tasks are going to run until
after the event.
This is more of we all know exactly what
to do. There's no planning. There's no,
like if I ask anybody on this team,
what are they doing for the kickoff?
They should
at least be able to reference something
to know what it is.
That's what I'm calling complete.
Okay, so.
Like September 1st.
Shall I?
We should at least a week out before.
I think we can do that in one
conversation. I mean,
there might be things that need approval
and whatnot,
but we should have at least a list of how
to run this event, like a runner.
We have to run a show.
We should have the simple task items in
order to get everything completed.
I guess what I'm asking for,
and there may be another thing after this
one is complete.
So let's just say this is phase one,
the planning of it.
I think that shouldn't be any more than
two weeks.
Okay, so that takes us to July 1.
Yeah,
I would say July 1 just to have it all
locked in. Us know, you know,
who's doing what.
You know,
there may be smaller committees or what
have you, because this is an event,
but technically, right?
Correct.
So you just need to plan it like one.
So what I can do so we can move this
forward and move on to the next item is
I'll put together the kickoff item,
the kickoff document,
taking everything that we've discussed in
previous meetings this meeting,
and then I'll share it by our next
meeting.
And then that, then we, from there,
we can probably lock in dates and figure
things out. Does that work for everybody?
Yes, thank you.
Okay. QA process, same thing,
no updates on that.
I'll provide some additional clarity
within the next two weeks.
Give me two weeks from today as a
deadline for that,
one week for today for the kickoff.
Audio Eye, Tricia.
It's still a pain in our rear. Okay,
so my conversation with Sue though to I
met with Sue because remember Matt wanted
to meet with Audio Eye and Final Sight.
So Sue is explaining to me and I think I
wanted to ask the
the team to about final site.
But before I get that, Sue says, well,
Audio Eye is something that we purchased
and it didn't,
we didn't have to go with Audio Eye.
This is not what I know, but again,
I came into this late.
So let's say we didn't know that we
didn't have to go, yeah, exactly right.
We didn't know that we didn't have to go
with Audio Eye. We could have gone with.
Rudy,
I forget the one that you keep referring
to and I mentioned it to her.
Site improve. Yes.
Sign, improve.
Side improved,
but we were we were told that.
So she's saying that we could.
We didn't have an option. Yeah, I'm sorry.
Right. That's what I, right. So now,
now they're saying that we could choose
Yeah, we didn't have it. As far as I know,
we didn't have an option.
if it are. So again,
because I presented it to her that our
contract ends in March of next year and
we're going to RFP.
So I was very blunt with that part of it.
So she says,
It.
Well, it's not Final Sight,
it's Audio Eye and da da da da.
I don't care,
I'm lumping all y'all together, so...
Yeah.
she says, well,
can we possibly go with a different ADA
Li.
thing? Absolutely. But again, she says,
because you guys are paying for that
separately. Okay. So now it is, well,
can we go with site improve?
Right.
She's going to look at and can we get our
proper scan?
So she's going to go back to see if for
July,
can we get move this scan up to July for
the school site?
We will do one elementary, one middle,
The.
one high.
So I,
clearly she don't want to meet with Matt,
but we won't have to set up this meeting
with Matt.
But I'm going to see what she can do
first because, you know,
Matt's busy and trying to get on his
calendar is going to take two weeks
anyway.
Um...
So...
Her other, her other question was,
but then,
but you guys don't have a problem with
with final site, do you? Yeah,
we have a problem with final site.
Yeah.
We just got used to it.
We settled into the problem. Oh,
are things going to error every time we
click the publish? It's just what it is.
You just got to go to the boat publish.
That's not acceptable.
It's not, and it's still not fixed.
Almost a year in.
But.
Right.
Hold on, I got Farrah calling me.
I'm gonna give me one second.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I think that we need to document,
you know,
the three or five things that we have
issue with, with final site,
because she thinks final site is,
you know, Shangri-La or something. And
I, I wanna,
I wanna be clear when our for our meeting
next week that...
While it's not.
The dregs,
we still have concern with these
particular things on the final site side.
So yes,
we have the full whole Audio Eye issue
one. And in addition to,
there is concern on the final site side.
So, yeah,
so that was that was my meeting with her,
um, last week.
Okay.
Yeah.
To clarify, I thought Audio Eye,
I thought we weren't paying for Audio Eye,
I thought it was part of the package with
vinyl site.
No, according to her now, right.
So this is why I remember when I said,
well,
why can't we only got the scans for the
district and we didn't get the school
site scanned.
And she said it was to reduce costs
because to keep costs down,
because that's that was what the contract
stated or something like that.
I'm so sorry.
I have seen the contract.
I hate to derail this because I know
we're getting a lot of ground on this,
but Farrah has some updates on the on
Pompano, and I said,
rather than just tell me everything,
can I bring her into the meeting just to
Oh, sure.
give us the update? All right,
give me a second.
Oh, great, yeah.
Hello, hello.
Good morning.
Good morning!
How's everybody?
Good, how are you?
Living a dream. Living a dream.
Alright, so I gave them,
I gave them a quick update on what we
Is that it?
So I'm gonna.
were talking about, so they're primed.
OK, awesome.
So when I was in the region office and
working in Pompano,
we always use the large conference room
at Pompano Administrative Center,
which is on the campus of Pompano High.
But it's the administrative building.
If we were to go there, there isn't a fee,
but the room capacity is only 100.
So how long is the session?
Could we break it up?
Can we break it by levels?
Can we do multiple days?
I don't know what the request is,
but if we were to use Pompano Beach High,
I think it's going to be a fee associated
because they're closed on Friday.
So you have to pay for security pay for
custodial.
And all of those things that I don't know
whose budget were you think we could do
it for free 99?
So I know that's,
I'm going to say what's on my mind right
now.
That's a little different than what we
were thinking,
but if we were to shift to literally do
our workshops and follow that model,
so we could do a morning session schools,
Okay.
afternoon session departments,
because they could stay a little bit
longer.
then we would just build whatever it is
we're building for that.
Yeah.
So now we don't have to have multiple
rooms. They're going to.
People.
We literally run it like a workshop where
we're programming what they're doing
throughout those four hours.
I believe that that's what the time
Okay.
period would be.
And then it's a little scaled down from
what we're doing,
but we could still do everything that we
wanted to do. We'll just be focusing on.
Ohh.
Each one.
So what was the original vision?
So the original vision was to have the
auditorium.
Yeah.
It's kind of modeled what we used to do
with the TLC meetings.
They would bring us all into the
auditorium.
You have like some lot of light bites.
You know,
it's kind of like a celebratory
atmosphere.
Then they break off into the classrooms
and there's maybe like 4 dedicated
classrooms with different tracks.
And then like every couple of hours you
go to, maybe go to two tracks,
come back into the auditorium for lunch,
maybe some announcements,
things of that nature.
Then we have a session in the auditorium
for everybody.
Break out again for the final breakout
Ohh.
sessions,
maybe two more breakout sessions.
And we wrap, we wrap in those,
then we come back into the auditorium,
OK.
wrap up,
and then everybody goes out in their
merry way. But it's everybody at once.
It's school and departments all meeting
in that auditorium.
And then so teachers TLC's whomever are
the web content managers at the school
will be on the TD.
Drew.
Leave the school and everybody would be
there on a Friday.
Correct.
So in the past, how have we done this?
I think Tricia has her hand up.
We've never hosted.
A training like this and definitely
haven't provided light bikes or food.
Yeah.
And where's the budget and how has this
been done before?
Okay.
Yeah.
Right, this is a first.
Oh.
Yeah.
OK.
I was a guy walking in eating the light
bites, so I don't know how they did it.
Be.
That's probably when the money was
flowing from the trees and from the
fountains and stuff.
So, is it possible?
I know I'm kind of going to a separate,
I'm talk to like light bytes,
but I will come back to light bytes,
but is it possible to use author Ash? So,
we know we've used author Ash in the past,
right?
to do and it doesn't cost anything.
And I don't know if that room is bigger
than the space. To me,
that large conference room over in the
administrative building is not that big.
Right.
But Arthur Ash,
I know that it that we've done that for
the principal's meeting.
That's large enough.
Okay.
But I don't know that they have breakout
rooms either.
OK.
I know they have like the library and
like the little computer room by the
library there,
the media in their media center,
but I don't know what the what the
capacity is.
Like,
so when we did our training last year,
we just brought like water and I went and
got stuff at Publix. You know,
they buy one,
get one free of the morning tax.
But now you're talking 100 and some
people.
We were having smaller sessions each day.
But those couple of days that we were
over at, what was that, Sheridan?
Um...
that, you know,
so we could definitely manage.
Like mites,
but location is location is key.
Right.
I just have never paid for it or did this
before, so it's just pouring to me.
Right.
So I don't.
I know there's always been district
training.
I don't even know if we're supposed to
pay and they just sent us the link.
Like I've never hosted a district
training.
And went through that process.
So if you're always done it with TLC's or
web content managers,
or what's different this year that we're
reaching out to Pompano.
And may have to do a cost.
Like, are we doing something wrong?
What's what I would say what's different?
No, I don't. I think it's different.
The difference is that I last year,
I believe that we were and what's his
name?
Ohh.
Was the project manager for final site?
Robert, thank you.
Robert.
Robert reached out to the various places
to find us locations, right?
And they, there, there wasn't a cost,
but again, that was during school time,
so the, you know, I think that that's why.
Right, and part of that too,
we could only host 20 individuals per
session. So in terms of capacity,
we were okay with the classroom setting,
but now we're trying to accommodate all
WCM. So it could be up to about 400 WCM,
300 on the school side,
maybe 100 on the department side.
So we have definitely more WCM to account
for for this type of event.
OK.
So there will be costs associated if
we're doing it at Pompano with breakout
rooms,
because they'll have to have staff you
know.
To.
Custodial staff and set up and whatever
the fees associate.
Uh-huh.
So according to Brenda, it's about $1,000.
So
Because it's not for school out.
I guess.
I will have,
I'll ask to see where where that but
number budget comes from.
I can ask Nikki at the ISD to see where
would which.
And it may be the Chiefs requesting it.
And there's no fee.
Yeah.
I just don't know.
I just never done this before.
M.
No.
Well,
we could start a collection and everybody
puts something in by the time we get
around.
Try to cover fee, get tote bags.
We want to do a car wash.
You can do a car wash, yeah.
We can get sponsors.
4.
I.
Yes, we can always ask.
But...
Yeah, I think sponsors would be easy.
They can do giveaways.
We can check with district community
relations to see if there anybody would
love the opportunity to be in front of,
you know,
decision makers when it comes to web and
technology and whatnot. And I think it
Be a nice little.
Budget to put behind for future events,
too, as well,
and we could see if it even works, I mean.
Time sponsorships for less, so,
and we have some time.
All right,
so I just was doing my due diligence to
So, do we need money?
Farrah,
you just put a damper on our meeting.
see what.
I just want you to know.
Hey I might not be the person with the
answers.
Yeah.
I just was trying to figure out what is
the process.
I have no idea.
I've never hosted a district training.
Yeah.
I'm usually just invited to come and
speak and I'm just gonna speak so I've
never set up anything or done anything.
On the logistics side,
so there may be a process where we don't
have to pay and I just don't know what it
is 'cause. I've never done it before.
Is it worth just,
is it possible that we can just do like a
soft reservation where we just put our
information down and then, you know,
if it becomes available that we don't
have to pay, then we're, you know,
at least we're in the books.
Or do we not go that route because we're
not sure right now,
especially with those planning.
Yeah.
I have no idea.
Okay.
'Cause it's facilitron.
All he did was send us the link to
Facilitron,
which is the facilities leasing site.
Oh.
So I I don't know what the parameter.
I think that's where the cost came in and
you need security and you need this and
you need that.
All of that was in the link for the
Facilitron registration right, Sean?
Yeah, I didn't click through the link,
but if that's the case, I'm thinking who,
which department is that?
Chris akabusa.
Do you know the name of that?
I'm trying to think like who's the WCM,
Uh.
because that could be a route that I can
go,
is I can speak to the WCM and get the
insight.
Facilit. Oh my God. I'm looking at it.
I can't think of it.
So...
Real estate and facility planning.
Yeah, I was going to say,
I was just because I was on with them,
Okay.
the facilitron people and our internal
people.
Great real estate and facilitate.
Do you have a connection to that
department?
Eloy. Eloy. Quesada. QUESADA.
Okay, maybe we go that route, just,
you know, unofficially find out,
let them know what we're working on and
say, you know,
what's possible for us to not have to,
whatever the situation.
I mean,
there have been a number of district
training, so they have a process.
I just don't know.
What it is?
Gotcha. All right.
So I think that's the next step is to
figure out what is the process,
what do we need to do?
Ohh.
Then we plan around that.
That'll let us know kind of what our
****.
options are,
come up with some alternatives. Like,
let's say we do want to have this event,
but we know we're not going to be able to
come out of, you know, any of our budgets,
you know, what else is possible.
I think if we're allowed to do the
sponsorship route,
we could work with DCR and figure out
maybe there's people they're speaking to
for other things that they can,
this could be a good, you know,
if this particular type of audience,
there's people who want to speak to
people who aren't necessarily consumers,
people who are decision makers and things
Okay.
of that nature.
We could spin it that way. So yeah,
let me put some ideas.
I have to put together a brief on this
anyways,
and I'll share it out with everybody,
and then we'll just go from there.
Alright, anything before?
All good.
And then I did get a A since the web team
is here,
Okay.
Mhm.
they get a lot of feedback yesterday in
the leadership week presentations,
Yeah.
not the overarching presentation that we
had,
Okay.
Bing.
but we did individual sessions on social
media.
We did 6 sessions like 50 people,
each principals, APS and.
M.
They I got.
I told them that we're creating a website
governance team to address their concerns.
Okay.
So that's the short of it.
They did bring up.
They don't have the autonomy and they
can't update this and so on and so forth.
And I shared with them what has been
shared numerous times.
Ohh.
You do have access to update your post
your internal pages and everything except
that web showcase banner,
your pride points and certain elements
that we're trying to hold secure for
branding.
Yeah.
And mark?
But then the questions came up about,
you know,
No.
the activities and athletics and how do
we do certain things?
Ohh.
So I think that discussion we had around
website governance really needs.
Go.
To move forward and we invite the
principals in to get feedback and input
Okay.
from them,
especially going into the end of the
contract and what we're doing beyond a
year from now.
And then on that note,
I shared the updated notes.
Bing.
So this is the second link that I shared.
The first one might not be working.
And then just let me any updates,
any notes,
Okay.
anything that you want to see on there,
just reply back in that email and I'll
Yes.
give an updated draft as well.
And that's anyone else who was on that
OK.
Yeah.
email.
you can do the same.
And then the governance as well,
Okay.
I shared that out with you.
So once I hear back from you,
Charlene and Tricia,
any notes that you guys have regarding
that,
that's more of just a capture of all the
Hello.
Or.
conversations that have happened.
I will then share it out with the large,
Go.
Open.
with Manny and the larger team.
Because I think that's what they're
waiting on to schedule the next meeting.
Because I know we have the AI meeting,
which is something different later this
week.
So the people that were I guess
proficient and good at having that
economy,
they feel like they're being punished for
the ones that didn't do or don't do and
don't update.
I.
And they're in their feelings about it.
And they keep expressing it so.
And it's mostly the high school peak.
Remember your book that you were reading,
Farrah? Let them. We're going to say that.
Mm.
Yeah.
But I I think some of their concerns are
valid so.
I did,
in speaking to the activity section,
I did put a reach out to the athletics
department just to get clarification on
what should be standardized on these
pages,
because we are looking at creating a new
template,
just as we've done for the other sections
like magnet.
So we are looking into, you know,
standardizing the athletic section,
Oh.
but we do need to connect with Patricia
Brown and team or whoever she thinks that
we should connect with.
So I did send out an email last week
pertaining to that.
But I know one of the things that really
came up and like other issues that they
have expressed is, you know,
changing the activities to athletics for,
you know,
Good.
high schools and things like that.
So this is where having that,
A.
Yeah.
like you said, the governance,
moving forward with that so that we can
Oh.
address a lot of their issues.
There were others as well when it came to
Okay.
Yeah.
the high schools.
So we should definitely move on that
Li.
sooner.
The later I'm agreeing with that.
Stop.
No.
Agreed. Agreed.
All right,
I think that's what we all have all we
Ohh.
have for you, Farrah.
If you more than more than welcome to
The.
stick around if you want to hear the rest
of this meeting, then we're wrapping up.
No, you're gonna give me more work.
I'm signing off.
All right, thank you so much.
Bye.
Matthew.
Brannon.
Me too.
Alright, alright.
Eloy is out,
so I'm sending a message to Ryan Kubler,
who's assistant.
Ryan Kugler.
Assistant area supervisor for maintenance,
physical plant operations.
He's who just said to contact when he's
out, while he's out.
So because he's out this whole week.
So, we'll see what he says.
Oh,
we got celebrity working in our district.
Ha ha ha!
Black Panther director. All right.
All right, so I interrupted you guys.
It looked like we were having a great
conversation about audio.
Was it Audio Eye?
Yeah, I'm off that soapbox now.
Yes.
Okay,
I'll review the notes because I missed
most of it.
Just a quick, just a quick information.
I don't know, but we had,
Yeah.
when we had Site Improve, Site Improve,
one of the issues that we had with Site
What?
Oh.
Improve was they were charging us our
contract call for 25,000 pages.
Yeah.
We had 40 at the time.
So they were trying to get more money
Yeah.
from us because we had 40,
000 pages on our site.
Yeah.
From what I'm seeing in final site,
we have some close to 70,
The.
000 if we haven't reached that number yet.
So whatever we do with wherever we if we
Okay.
Yeah.
go back to final site,
obviously the expense is going to be
higher until we until until we can
control the the page count.
Bing.
Um, on, on, on final site, so...
Oh.
That was one of the reasons why we moved
to audio. I,
Yeah.
the main one being that we didn't,
at least I didn't,
they told us it came with final site and
there wasn't going to be a charge for it.
It was just part of final site. Again,
I wasn't in those major meetings where
All right.
that might have been communicated
internally, but it didn't come back to me.
So.
Um,
but I know that signing proof did did
charge for per page, so...
Okay.
And one thing to note,
especially with the pages for deletion,
Just.
I know that, yes,
our page count is pretty high,
but we do need to do a purge.
We talked about during the summer that we
would have instructed the WCM to kind of
empty out their pages for deletion
section.
So that's something that going into the
new year,
that may be a task or something that we
bring up during the training.
Um, you know, to start off the new year,
you know, to some housekeeping.
And that can be added to their monthly
update, too.
Or added to their monthly, yeah,
or added to the monthly after, correct.
Okay.
So that's probably an area where we can
address a lot of the page counts is and
is having them to purge.
Or do they have access?
I think that was another issue too.
We were going to transition and to making
sure they have access,
but there's some things we need to work
on in the background.
to make sure that they have access to
delete pages.
And there needs to be a lot of cleanup
because not all WCM move their.
Yeah.
Transition pages to pages for deletion,
so there's still a lot of pages out there
Play.
on the websites.
Okay.
Right.
OK,
we can add that as a as an action item to
make sure we don't lose track of it.
BCPS Central.
Yay, BCPS Central. Hot topic.
This is a work in progress.
We're working to make sure that come the
start of the new year,
Yeah.
or should I say come July 1,
principals will be able to assign their
WCM. So there's a lot of moving parts.
with BCPS Central. So Sean, I just,
I think we addressed it at the beginning
of this call.
I sent you the top three for all the
different versions that we need to
include to the SOW so that we can give
that to Yaco.
But we've broken up into three versions
where by October we would have like a
completed.
not really completed,
but we will be on the right path,
should I say,
when it comes to BCPS Central.
But there are a lot of moving parts.
I know the team is independently working
Yeah.
on summer updates,
so we'll need to transition those audit
reviews or what the team is working on
into BCPS Central.
So we do need to talk about what
that looks like.
I'm going to be working before this week
is over. Wait, I only have two days,
my goodness,
to do the 25-26 audit checklist.
The idea is that we would use that as a
main template per se, and then...
the team will go in and indicate for
those schools that are still in the fail
or incomplete status will indicate what
they have completed.
So when the WCM returns,
they will have to work on whatever is
outstanding for 25-26. But again,
a lot of moving parts,
still work in progress.
I don't have a deadline per se date,
but definitely by June 30th,
we do know what we
what we need to have completed and that
is in the document that I showed with you,
Sean.
Okay,
I was trying to look at it right now,
but my screen is all black for some
reason for my teams.
Ohh.
Okay.
Does this ever happen to anybody?
Not it going black, not like that, no.
Ohh.
Bye.
Okay, all right, I'll do it afterwards.
If I remember.
We got Canvas course pilot launch.
Working on that,
Hello.
I had a meeting with Felicia right before
this.
So we're going to do a sprint tomorrow
and try to knock out as much as we can.
Yeah.
And then,
and then go from there and WCM
Ohh.
communication plan.
You, Vanessa, you, you, you get a,
you get a first draft, right?
Yeah,
I'm still working on that because I met
with Rudy yesterday and so much more came
to light.
So I'm working on a different version of
this communication plan.
It's including all the different types of
communications that we're going to send
out between now and, I guess, October.
But it's still a work in progress.
Hopefully by Monday I can have a
completed version.
Okay, alright, sweet, so.
So let's go ahead and move to departments
K through 12 pages.
Update that to Thursday the 11th.
Way to embed pages, so I think we...
Tricia, you said that's solved,
that's complete.
Yes, I need to test it. Matter of fact,
let me just do that right now. Yes,
they had to turn on something on the
final site side in order for it to work.
Mhm.
And I just need to open up a page and
test it.
Okay.
I love you.
Of.
I'll get back to you in a moment.
All right, while Tricia is doing that,
we gotta do... It's working? All right,
Oh, yep, it's working.
Mhm.
so could...
Okay.
All right, so let me close.
So there was somebody who initiated.
Were you in touch with them or you're
going off of this?
You were checking just based off of this.
The.
I just want to see if I need to close the
loop or if you're already in touch with
that person.
No,
I figure once they told me that they did
what they were supposed to do,
I don't need to be bothered with them
anymore,
but I need to close a loop with them.
I, if you, if you think it's closed,
you're good.
I open.
So I was the one that opened the ticket
with them.
If they want their ticket closed,
that's on them. They SLA is running up.
I'm glad that the thing is working.
No worries, I'm good.
I just want to close the loop. So you're,
I'm closing the loop based of what you
said. I'm putting this into the complete.
We are done. Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding.
We got, we got a win here.
Yes. Yep. And you're no longer sharing,
just in case.
Oh, I am not.
And I'm looking at it like you are seeing
Mhm.
what I'm seeing. Give me a second here.
Share, share, like, and we're together.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Here we go.
No.
Okay.
Ways and.
Now I understand.
As I learn more about you, Sean,
now I understand why songs roll off your
tongue.
I thought I was just a crazy woman,
but I'm not into music like that. But,
you know,
I hear a word and I go into singing songs.
My niece and I are,
we correct my sister with this.
But I see where it comes from with you
now.
Audit OOC pages. Yeah,
that came out of our last meeting.
Why did we say,
what was the urgency for this OOC managed
pages? Academic section.
For Crystal Lake Middle.
I don't know what that means.
Academic section for Crystal Lake Middle.
Okay, I don't know what that means,
but I do know we need to,
I need to look at the OOC pages because I
think there's certain,
there was something that was off that
made me realize that.
It hasn't been audited.
Like of all these audits, I haven't,
we haven't done,
I don't think we've done a solid audit on
our own pages.
So that's what that represents. And.
So, what?
Go ahead.
If you click the notes,
does that break down the notes from the
last meeting?
I'm just curious what this is too,
only because it says Crystal Lake Middle.
No, it doesn't have anything yet.
Okay.
Yeah, this is just this is all fresh.
I could potentially populate old notes in
there. I don't see that being an issue.
But what would happen is based off what
Home.
we discussed today,
next time you look at this,
those notes will be listed here. And then
Yeah,
and this is where the description will
help too.
Mhm.
Versus the notes.
So based off what you're hearing,
create the context to do a 150 character
Two.
Okay.
description for each of these tasks.
And then we'll review it and see if
anything's off. And then, yeah,
so automate left batter. Okay,
where are we? Audit OOC pages.
Let's go with.
the 17th for that as a deadline.
Left navigation structure, Vanessa.
I'm trying to remember.
The left navigation,
I'm going back to the spreadsheet because
Uh...
this is not aligning.
The left navigation is about the
academics of Crystal Lake,
which is what you have going on with OOC.
I pushed it down.
The 2 things didn't align, didn't line up.
Okay,
so that's this I have it up on my screen
Okay.
too. So academic section for Crystal Lake.
It's still.
Hello.
The mix.
Your update last was working on it.
Because I remember calling, okay,
so put in a ticket to make sure that we
have breadcrumbs. Maybe that's it.
Maybe it's the breadcrumbs. Andrea,
I think you might have brought this to
our attention to some months ago.
That could be it.
Let me just check another school to see
if they have breadcrumbs.
I think that's what it was,
that we didn't have consistency across
our schools.
Yes, I remember, but I don't remember.
Okay.
Yeah.
Clear as mud.
On Special Ed.
Yeah.
So I just spot checked another school and
I'm noticing breadcrumbs.
So this may have been resolved,
but I can go back to that original ticket
to confirm, but I'm noticing breadcrumbs.
Before it was not consistent.
Some sites had it, some pages had it,
some didn't.
And then final site had to go in and
adjust
the template to include the breadcrumbs.
I think that's what it is.
Academics.
Yeah, I think, yeah, I think we're good.
I think we could close this out.
Okay.
My school.
Ask.
All right, moving on,
automate message for rejected banner
Oh.
images.
Who's that automate? Is that Tricia? Okay.
That's Tricia.
Oh, sorry.
Ohh, OK. Yes, it's the one.
Um...
I am, Melanie is out.
So I am going to see if my team of
interns, we're going to talk about,
this is one of our projects that I have
on our list that they can work on.
So we're going to work,
we're working on it.
But when do we have a deadline on that?
Okay,
Put a deadline.
Ohh, I want to commit.
After deadline.
July 8th. No,
I'm out of the office that week.
So we got to go back up one.
That's 3 weeks. We can get it done three.
July 1st.
Little after that.
Gay.
In July 1st,
and that was the automate message for
rejected banner images.
Correct.
OK,
and what was the deadline for left
Yeah.
navigation structure?
No, that's completed.
OK, completed, that's right. OK,
mark that as completed.
Tricia, did I, I know it's been some time,
do you have the templated message?
Did I give you that? I think I did.
For the automated messages.
Yeah, I think it's in.
I think it's in the flow already. Yes.
It's already okay, perfect. Okay.
Yes,
I believe I'm going to pull up the floor.
I believe it's already in there.
That's not the part of the flow that's
not working.
Power of me.
And while you pull that out,
speaking of banner images,
can we close out?
this and I'm not sure how that impacts
you, Tricia.
Okay.
Can we close out this form so we can
start a new form for the new school year?
Okay.
Oh.
So you created the form, right?
Mhm.
Feel free, just let me know.
Okay.
Yeah, no problem.
Rudy, are you still receiving?
Are there still submissions coming in?
Yeah.
Um, I can look.
Because they they also came from teams.
Because if I close out the form.
Yeah, uh,
submissions for which submissions for
which one?
Banner.
No, I don't think.
I think there may be one out there that
came in,
but I haven't really looked this week
because I've been on other stuff.
Let me look real quick.
Thursday,
one came in for Deerfield Beach last
Thursday.
That was the last one to come in.
Let me see if that's,
let me see if that's completed or not.
Play.
So, how?
Okay, so how will this work then moving?
If we close it out and the link is still,
can we reopen it and start a new form?
And then before that,
Nova was the one before that on 6-2.
So say that again, if you close it out,
we're not going to, we're going to close,
we're going to close it.
They would have to be,
I don't know where the link is that
they're using, that would have to be,
because are they using like a vanity URL
or are they using a direct link from
somewhere?
They're using the the Teams,
the the forms link.
We don't have a vanity URL for this.
So the forms link is in Teams,
where are they going to go get that forms
link?
The forms link has been distributed
through various channels,
And the sweat.
whether it's the hub, the sway, chats,
you know.
Right.
Right,
so I would say we communicate that
there's a new link and just put the new
link out.
Oh, so when we close it,
it's not like we could just close the
form and we reinstate it.
We can't do that.
I don't know. I love.
Yeah.
Not that I'm aware of.
I don't know that you can do that.
Ali.
So is it worth closing then?
Because there are...
So, so, so I mean,
what you what you could do is save what
is in the existing form, right?
Save it with a new name.
And continue using,
and then delete the contents out and
continue using the form.
Alright, say that last piece again.
you would continue to delete what is in
the form. So you save, save it,
save what we have today.
With a new name.
Oh, okay.
The, you know,
the responses with a new name.
Okay.
Top me to a new file or whatever,
and then delete the contents of,
Okay.
and then delete the content out,
and then you can continue using it.
I like that idea. Thank you.
I wouldn't advise that.
You would not advise that?
That's not that's not a clean way to do
things.
Okay.
Um...
But it is a way.
Okay,
it just in terms of some people might
have that link bookmarked, you know,
if they're coming into the summer and
Right, right.
they want to get ready to school and then
we now switch on and then they're not
And if they bookmark,
but if they bookmark it,
aware.
what you can do is just on the first page
on the existing one, on the first page,
you rename it just like we did before,
right? You say, there's a new link,
here's a new link on that opening and you
close out the question, all the questions.
Ohh.
So you can do that on the form.
Remember we did that before?
All right, for the enrollment.
For open enrollment or something like
that.
Yeah, one of them, I don't remember.
One of those things. Okay. All right,
so we got options. All right.
Mhm.
Thank you.
OK, can you hear me?
Yes.
Okay, so that was which one?
Automate, uh,
automate messages for rejected banners.
Mhm.
Mmh.
Okay. School mini base,
I need to schedule a call with final site
to push a migration of documents.
So that's just pending.
And once I do that,
I'll feel confident that I know how to do
mini bases for the most part.
Then it'll just be me reteaching it,
making a video to reteach it.
So I'll probably just do it again on
video. And then once I have that,
that'll be a solid base for people to
learn mini bases.
And then I may reproduce it again in a
short series that I do through the hot
I.
labs. So that's just,
that's where we are with the mini bases.
And then following up with the people who
do have mini bases.
What?
So I might just make a smaller committee.
of, not committee, a smaller group,
I remember words are powerful here,
a small group of people who have many
bases and then just focus on them at
Call.
first. And then once,
and then now kind of,
I probably loop them into the mini,
into the pilot program for that.
I.
And this work on.
Yeah.
fine-tuning that.
And then as far as deadlines for that,
Yeah.
let's say,
let me get myself before the end of the
month because I'm out for a few days.
I'll be out from July 6th through the...
15th.
What am I doing? 30th.
So we'll do June 30th for that.
We can just combine mini,
but they won't host.
Why are you the lead for that?
That might be wrong.
Let's combine all mini base into one task
and it'll just be 1 mini base brief that
I can put together.
Bing.
school board records.
I think there's nothing else for us to do
with this, right?
They're going to move on to Granicus.
And is there anything else the district
web team needs to do?
Nope.
All right, so then this can go into,
this can go into, oh,
I do have an update on that as well.
This can go into completed.
I spoke to before and after school care
and they pretty much said they don't,
Yeah.
they decided to go a different route from
their mini base and they're using another
platform.
I did get some information regarding that
platform.
Are you guys familiar with what they're
doing? Let me start there.
No, no.
Oh.
So they,
she pretty much laid out everything that
they're doing in a hot lab.
It's in the recording.
I got to get reference of it,
but I said it was, it was,
I'm glad that we had the conversation
because this is one of the things I
discovered when we first launched the
committees way back,
way back in the day when Vanessa and I
launched these committees.
We learned,
it was a good way for us to learn what
other departments were doing in their
silos.
And there was one instance where
academics was working on a project that
was just being requisitioned by IT for
the whole district.
And they were using a whole different
vendor.
And we were able to like squash it right
then and there.
because we were able to find out from the
WCM in their meetings.
So stuff like that I feel is another
advantage of having these conversations
Okay.
and having the community,
because now we know that departments,
No.
at least not to my knowledge and
apparently not to anyone on this call's
knowledge,
has a mini-based solution that they're
using.
I don't want to say mini-based,
but they found an alternative that
they're using outside of final site.
So I'm saying all that to say we can look
into it. You know, it could be,
it's not a situation of like, well,
Okay.
they're doing their own thing,
but it's like, hey,
Okay.
what we have isn't completely sufficient
to what we want.
If it's something that can be integrated,
that can be used,
we can at least look at it now.
We have that information,
so I'll pull that, I'll pull that,
and I'll share it with you guys once I
process the hot lab meeting notes in the
next couple of days.
All right.
Thank you.
And then that's it. I mean,
can WCM Communications to communicate can
come. I think there's some communications.
I'm going to start doing a weekly touch
Okay.
point with the WCM,
especially with the content that I'm
creating.
I'm still figuring out what the flow and
layout because I want to provide value.
So probably not going to launch it.
right away,
but I am thinking about doing it.
I used to do it and I pulled back from it,
but my goal is it's more content-based
Yes.
and thus you need to do this right now
based and then...
having the cadence,
it's an easy way just to put in some of
that urgent stuff, like, hey,
here's what you need to do.
So I'll let you guys know what that look.
Go ahead.
Sean, question.
Are the department WCM also the
SharePoint point person?
I don't know for a fact.
I would be making assumptions saying yes.
Mm.
I think we need to align with that
because again, you know, Barry,
Barry on our team,
he's working with them for SharePoint
thing.
And I'm just thinking if it's the same
person,
then maybe you can glean some more
information from them and what they're
doing.
Does Barry have, does Barry have his, um,
does Barry have a list of all of his
Like a list.
SharePoint contacts?
With the departments,
because then we can just cross-reference
Right, right. Let me ask him.
it.
So that would be a good action item on
this task.
K.
Andrew, can you check your teams, please?
Is that something you should ask?
Oh.
Oops.
Lastra.
Can I do what?
Check to me.
Can I do what, Sir?
Teams, your message on Teams,
I message you on Teams.
Oh.
Gay.
Um...
All right, cool.
Bing.
So we're going to keep moving.
Department hot labs,
kind of already talked about it.
Anything that needs to be said about
Yes.
school hot labs.
Non-existent.
Okay.
No,
we're running through June 30th and
everything seems to me.
We had some lady jump in yesterday with a
Ohh.
Oh.
question about...
I don't remember what the question was,
but she had a question, and...
Okay.
Might have been BBK or something,
but yeah,
we have one lady jump in and we'll have
another hot lab. Like I said,
tomorrow and next week through June 30th,
and we'll go and then we'll stop for a
while.
Okay. Yeah,
we're probably going to stop in July as
Ohh.
well, but we'll see.
It's either going to be we stop or
Felicia will take over.
We'll discuss offline Felicia on that.
Bing.
I think I didn't mention that in our
meeting. And then the pending items,
do any of these items need to be moved
out of pending or are they still pending?
We have program school maps on district
server.
SharePoint, All School Master List,
and then Old Dillard Museum.
The.
No.
Yeah, old alert is in pending.
SharePoint master list.
Mm.
That was Andrea was working on updating
that document. How's that going, Andrea?
I think you're working on the principal
list or the AP,
adding APs to that master list.
Okay.
Yes, and I'm just writing Tricia,
it's not finished.
Tricia.
School, so.
Another thing, the software list.
So, let's set, so let's separate,
let's separate these two tasks.
Software.
Let's have the add assistant principals
and add that to this. What is,
what would that be?
The school final sites of WCM schools.
Uh...
That's a question.
Probably doing it.
And another issue,
don't forget all these principals and
assistant principals just change schools,
so...
Ohh.
Yeah.
Right, so we have the list.
I believe I sent, oh, Mr.
Ryan wants to call me.
This is about the using facilitron.
Make it back to y'all,
so let me go talk to.
OK, send me that,
send me the new list of principles though.
But.
You know what?
Okay, but we have two things going on.
I was asking about the software list,
not the principal list,
because I thought principal list was done.
Yeah.
No, I don't think so.
All right.
So for the purposes of the notes,
for the purposes of the notes,
It.
let me just get this in real quick and
you guys can continue.
We're going to move the SharePoint all
school master list to back into the
school, WCM schools,
and then we're going to keep updating
logos for summer in the pending tasks.
Is that correct?
Is Tricia still in this meeting or she
goes, she went supplies? Okay,
She's on hold.
so just to clarify something,
the software list is completed based on
the schools that we found the agreement.
If we didn't find an agreement,
there was nothing to put there,
but the list itself is done.
So I don't know who's taking care of that,
but I just wanted to clarify that.
And then principals list, no,
that's not done.
All right,
so we moved it into the active column,
Yeah.
and then the logos are going to be kept
for the summer.
And then we're going to put Andrea as the
lead on the logos,
and Andrea as the lead on the SharePoint
with Vanessa as support.
And that'll be the update to that one.
And that completes our list,
unless there's anything else we need to
add or discuss.
OOC is complete.
Is application service complete?
Ah, yes, thank you.
Alright, everyone.
Anybody else on the team? Anybody good?
Yes.
All right, everybody, have a great day,
and I guess I'll speak to some of you in
Yes, indeed.
meetings today and tomorrow.
Alrighty, have a good one.
Thank you, have a good day.
Thank you guys, bye.
All right, bye bye.
Okay, bye-bye.
Fine.